[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour a tous je veux d'abord dire que
c'est un honneur et un plaisir pour ma
première expérience au promu directeur
marketing dans une multinationale de la
passe et j'ai une expérience faune
africaine en construction de marque le
changement d'avis de consommateurs
durant toute mon expérience en passant
par l'afrique du sud nigéria l'un
travaillant sur des pays comme
l'ethiopie l'angola la rdc
la nourrice j'arrive à établir que nous
sommes tous des baraques et certain que
je vais adorer a prévu d'y aller
[Musique]
pas
on va parler de ma réponse de désigner
ses parts à ma part c'est sûr qu'on a
par avance à s'amender personne de
formation marketing là est un ensemble
d'éléments distinctifs qui a sans créer
de la valeur pour les consommateurs et
que l'élément distinctif la roja par
exemple au gouvernement pour une
proposition aux roses a des valeurs et
bientôt vous
et on va le savoir
en plus de toutes ces personnes dans
cette salle je vois beaucoup plus de mal
sur les vêtements les lunettes de vous
porter les dossiers que vous mettez et
est donc encore là marc nesme a grandi a
mûri et mvs pas comme là
mais il est bon de noter qu'il ya des
marques qui arrivent a duré longtemps et
qui arrive à accroître leur base de
consommateurs des clients et de notre
expérience j'ai pu comprendre j'ai pu
voir mais c'est marc qui arrivait à
tenir dans le temps et à prospérer avec
plus qu'au lendemain et justes dans
l'eau elle avait aussi un
conditionnement étaient claires avait
une vision
vous avez une mission l'avait des
valeurs elle avait pour but l avait un
élément de différenciation
voilà j'ai mis en rouge la proposition
résout veux m'attarder un peu plus d'eux
à propos du sort de la marsa ce que la
marque on s'en fout et ce à quoi vous
l'associez
vous donne ici par exemple mais y'a bien
connu dans la coca cola détergents au
mot même de propositions de la marque
coca cola pour par les verts après six
ans de tapuach écran ou le coca cola ou
en cours précise la map au et dans les
métastases
l'autre c'est les messages choisit pas
ses mots là ils sont utilisés dans la
communication dans tout ce que la moitié
jusqu'au bout les consommateurs peuvent
retirer proposition d emma et vous aimez
votre proposition
or le contrat the beauty exercice est ce
que chacun peut dire à son voisin et là
ça pose
[Musique]
d'accord dangereux sourit je vois
certaines versions initiales
je recevais une personne le besoin
d'adaptateur course en la personne qui y
ont déjà pensé
en anglais on dira général watts sont
tous des humains mais on doit pouvoir
être associé à quelque chose j'ai
quelque chose d'un collègue mouvement
mourir au préalable que des filles et en
sorte que dans notre comportement dans
tout ce qu'on fait on puisse le laisser
de laisser paraître
ok donc c'est cela le fond de mon
intervention vori c'est que nous sommes
tous de marne
nous avons tous une proposition pouvoir
et les partenaires parce que le premier
a pas pensé mais ya une bonne raison
qu'ils regardent et même au sein de la
cellule familiale
souvent les parents ont pu bien enfants
de constater mission par un s'agit de
donner la raquette plein pour une date
bien avant m
on ne le donne pas de moi
[Musique]
s'il ya un événement on dit qu'on vient
de demander la main d'une de nos soeurs
et qu'on a besoin de quelqu'un qui va
recevoir à sa famille ma belle famille
on sait qu'ils mettent en avant parce
que il amènera tout il ou elle à mandera
pour moi et prôner les valeurs
culturelles et bien offert
deux des traditions donc il s'agit de la
perception de chacun de nous l'espagne
le chacun de nous donne à son entourage
il ya dans sa famille ses amis et puis
la caméra il n'apprend pas de deviner la
proposition conférence
il est tellement important parce que
quand on ne l'a pas fait lors de notre
vie on gracie l'enfance ans de carrière
y en aurait q le décident de d'arrivée
par exemple en cours de chemin revoir
entre pairs carrière on dit maintenant
on veut donner un prix à adieu c'était
bien et a des gens qui le font un après
reviennent dit non je veux ouvrir au
moins ça travaille normalement leur
donner des exemples de quatre
expériences que j'ai vécues
ils montrent que ça faisait comme en
irak mois donc avant une proposition à
voir des scènes respectifs de la marque
avant 2 je voudrais vous ment avec le
référencement profit la pousse on l'a
fait c'est quoi donc
avant d'intégrer le groupe unilever dans
un programme de ces trente mille
candidatures et en afrique manager
français maître des airs avec dix
emplacements
dans ce genre de programme du 28 cieux
des objectifs
il appelle ingérable droite remportée
par 30 et à 19 ou d'une réputation de
distributeurs et par personne et le
comportement
l'idée reçue que tu à l'entrée il fait
que tu prennes en liberté alors que les
animaux étaient très bons techniquement
avec une averse vient d ouvrir des
portes aux écoles et à la fin de
l'évaluation des six premiers mois nous
montrer il avait atteint les objectifs
de commandes électriques étaient
parcours parce que son mari nyon et êtes
en train de faire la revue des
performances et des marins trident des
réseaux les gens arrivent ici ces deux
personnes on ne connaissait pas c'est à
dire en besoin d'entreprises qui forment
au boulot sont confinés dans leur coin
[Musique]
et ça c'est un problème et ça vient du
fait qu ils ne se sont pas vus comme des
maroons en recevant caen c'est quelque
chose qui est bon dans une compétence
particulière
il faut pouvoir exporter ya quelqu'un de
parler du numérique grande artiste du
paradis numériques et de
l'interprétation et c'est vraiment ce
rapport pour de vacances pour profiter
de bonnes et quand malheureusement ils
ont
sans sortir du programme et puis bon si
l'on recherchait 1 1 obtenu par ailleurs
un autre expérience encore j'ai eu trois
choristes en application une fois c'est
en réponse de passage à abidjan
j'étais logé dans un hôtel de la place
je suis plus sûr intéressant de réunion
j'aurais dû composer mon pied quelques
secondes dans de retour à 100 c'est vrai
que la personne lésée le ménage avec ses
rapports avec ce jeu je baise récupère
mes fans que j'avais laissé et en
sortant je tends mon ami le glass et
entre 1 6 turbo à la vie de classe de
cuisine et des très bons par les
déposants et les minima dans les
plantations de nous afin de faire partie
s'ils commencent à douter et on a
commencé à sombrer
je les aurais pris par la main vous avez
saisies il m'a dit comme ça que bon
c'est vrai les déboires de google ou de
vous la mienne enfants dont vous venez
au gré de novembre
la bulle a dû avaler les choses puissent
chercher un prix qui coule au et celle
animée sagan de zelda
dans les allées un peu plus de l'avant
et maintenant on voit déjà compétitifs
ici sa base si jean de ce week end dans
la pâte dans la nuit de lundi clairement
hâtivement tenait aujourd'hui le monde
qui s'offre à nous est beaucoup plus
difficile non va doubler l'effort de
vacances à l'aise nous nos enfants pour
les emmener là ils ont tous bêtise de la
bête
donc on doit travailler un peu plus
réponse est une excellente réputation
assez fort pour moi mais dire que ses
amis là il se voit qu'on démarre et
surtout le deuxième
malgré le csars est d'avoir un enfant de
route ils n'auraient pas arrivé parce qu
il allait viser haut
une main elles seront donc la revenante
nous sommes d'ailleurs jacques pin c'est
utile à la presse recruté la console et
vous voilà en fait j'ai rappelé les
différents éléments distinctifs là dans
le nom de ma tête tout seul me l'a dit
en deux heures
je mange moins vraiment rue mais
respecte hier peu moins huit filles à
100 je devrais une main on est assis
ville c'est une idée à manhasset avant
de marquer tôt si l'on dansait vegas le
positionnement jambes raisonnable
classes moyennes d'armement à niveau de
classe moyenne
ça me rappelle bien encore du chemin à
faire
[Musique]
la vision mon épouse heureuse et mes
enfants et ma mise en scène où je peux
reprendre dans un angle en passant par
the horizon maintenant d'éléments au
soir de ma vie qui pourra partir en paix
ma mission développement et renforcement
des capacités pour tous ceux qui le
pressent je pose de j'encadre ainsi papa
de jeunes à travers le vent tories et
puis des entreprises aussi pour les
fêtes d'antan de pas mal de la formation
on ne peut aller de l'avant ainsi on
apprend des choses j'en apprends à
laisser fondre cet âpre et valeur
travail d'équipé l'humilité la résidence
et les valeurs en fait vous verrez vous
proposera de 5 me connaissent en général
en relation les éléments que vont ils
vont sortir tout naturellement puis la
proposition de travail le
perfectionniste perfectionniste parce
que vous avez dans le marketing
on a des programmes qu'on dit quoi et où
et à la fin enfin si on veut des prix
on en parlait qu'est ce qu'un marché
parce qu'il faut améliorer les équipes
se sont toujours plaints du fait que je
veux juste qu'une des stars marché puis
deux heures de gloire mais c'est comme
ça il ya ce flambeau
[Musique]
élément de différenciation c'est la
détermination à réussir ma mère veuve ce
soir et vous le demandez comment est ce
que vous voulez vous dira c'est
quelqu'un qui l'accusera pas qui l'a pas
fait et ne laisse pas et c'est un peu ce
qui ressort de personnalité mes managers
des amis douteux vous savez quand vous
établissez votre console vous êtes vous
perçu 7 19 éléments dans ses filets
votre vie et la vie que vous voulez
avoir une puissance après avoir averti
qu'une gare du nord vous pouvez vous
orienter
ici je vais vous raconter une expérience
vécue comme un pont de 18 ans leur ya
dix ans de cela on savait que nos amis
ne devrait
est-ce quelqu'un de passionné du
renforcement des capacités développées
les legends est tous là j'étais
exactement
nous avons affaire révélée stable et en
4ème année avant la fin du stic on
assaisonne investi comme leader dans le
temps en 2016
on a remis leur démission intervient
dans la grèce a précisé la liste des
onze j'ai décidé de retourner mon père
est visible avant des mois l'exécutif a
donc décidé comme ça de retour et parce
que quand plus de lescar on voulait
avoir un autre rôle d'une des meilleures
universités de là bas on peut je puisse
plus tard au plupart portent visionnable
j'ai toujours eu envie d'avoir le
permettre ces différents pays me permet
de voir et bien vu à sculpter et là je
pensais comme ça déjà quand j'avais
vingt deux ans je pense que ce que je
vois là un rama yade revient en forme et
j'espère que ça coince d'exemple donc je
retourne et leur esprit de l'an la
soprano décès que vous avez ma mère
était absente
imaginez dans l'assistance a pas de père
lui est pas à vendre mais avec leur
logement dans un appartement
et de façon bien je me contente du
minimum parce que à ce stade là j'avais
peur tu peux apprendre franchi la
barrière que l'amabilité de devenir un
monsieur maintenant dans ce récit mis en
plus des cours de lundi à cesser le
travail à chercher du travail
j'ai déposé des cv dans différents
divertissements à différents endroits
faut dire aussi que j'aime les bonnes
zones dans ce travail permet des choses
que j'ai compris
plutôt que de demander pardon
[Musique]
par la grâce de dieu j'ai pu avoir un
stade que l'emploi reste en berne et une
entreprise au gothard a apprise un
dernier à part quelques uns du vin à dix
contre dix durant a cité dans ce stade
la période du monde et moi j'ai fait des
petits boulots étudiants ont pu avoir un
endroit un commentaire si auxerre est
une organisation caritative jerry et
yonne et hop et un grand building une
visite et d'assurance
et pas avant et puis en plus de sa
savane hauteur de l'écrire il encore à
disposer d'un supermarché et après ça à
20 août on sait que des médecins 10
heures un magazine qu'on appelle le doc
rivers dance 2 et passer commande
journée commencée dans 4 du matin il
fallait est en poste à peine 7 heures et
devrait être dispo dans le supermarché
quand je finissais la dspo vrai que je
revienne à la maison de santé avant
d'aller faire un stage de printemps et à
12h30 je devais trop beaux dans l'es5
15h erreur ce soir une des stations de
prêt 11,2 des jeunes à pratiquer des
expériences à domicile et pour pas le
souvenir de cette expérience
parce que rld développer
dans le reste de l'argent et les efforts
des parents envers la tendance avec un
parent à son peuple et une voix juste
envie nous avons des ados mais quand il
t'arrive d'expérimenter dans la
complexité dans les pays baltes et 10
degrés au sud afin de personnes âgées de
dollars aux passionnés de f1 soit fait
prendre conscience de l'année et tu peux
rapporter les efforts fournis par départ
ont dominé les parents cela m'angoisse
pour les fans la vie active à travers à
travers cette expérience tu tues à la
fête du vélo
même si un petit boulot d'étudiant à la
fin du mois
l'inconscient qui vient est revenu pour
me ans ou de moins ne propose rien donc
tout commence déjà à habitué à prendre
les choses qu'on fait un bond soit la
discipline et plus mais l'idée vous avez
environ 10 selon des travaux parus dans
les miens
j'étais presque et d'incliner puis en
direct tu peux être tentés de voir la
cause de trop non parce que c'était une
épreuve l'inexpérience
voilà donc ça m'a appris que tu peux
avoir quelqu'un ya un niveau et tu es
plus bas que le tien misera comparant
deux dans la rue est une règle à
respecter dernier hilary chasse
perpétuelle de la paix comme ça vous
savez quand tu fais du gaming en faire
une habitude est dit très souvent au
delà des choses qu'on voit comme ça là
quelque chose derrière continent noir
est temps de le vendre l'été qui le rend
parfait et que le faire de façon
régulière tu auras ton esprit avec
quelqu'un qui a ses sculptures et et qui
cherche de la propriété et de sauvegarde
ou se rendre dans nos bureaux du co2
deux hommes et j'ai vu les trouver il
avait la vakaga recteur dans celui ci je
dis moi je vous l'apprends pas le retour
au pays où vraiment passionnant plus
heureuse
m et là on monte un peu de temps mais
voilà pendant dix ans après aujourd'hui
j'occupe un poste raisonnable marketing
limited entre régions je n'ai pas la
réponse et disant attendre les partis
qui avaient une vision et une mission
car une proposition car l'un est loin
des différenciations quitté la compagnie
nationale dans mon travail pendant tout
l'apprentissage
c'était en partie le résultat de ce
territoire par saison quand vous êtes en
erreur vous avez la plupart des parents
envoient leurs enfants dehors il y en a
un qui se perdent parce qu'on commence à
faire des petits boulots et de courir
voilà les gones ne m'intéresse plus ça
c'est pas top en france
je veux rester incompris voire à sa
fusion qu'ils utilisent dans le nord la
peau du bras et puis tu peux obtenir ce
que tu eu ces quelques images donc
deux mois voici quelques images de
demander aux gens vrais j'étais inspirée
par l'expérience plafonné aussi parce
que durant dix semaines
il ya des gens souvent il m'a mais voilà
la réserve est essentiel dans les
réponses et dont j'avais de qalandia
reste de sauce nantua
l'américain l'a acquise à travers trois
points soit donc fausse preuve
d'humilité plus avoir d'enfant de
sources travail de contact déjà du plus
grand regret est aussi des trophées
enfin dans ce très joli levage balles de
lavage des mains avec kenya l'afrique
ben hamida nasa à une compétition
mondiale de la reina ne profite que nous
ayons au volant de la désactiver puis
tout récemment je viens d'être les murs
nous voici tous
finie la victime est un sport qui
demande que toute la bande son se
construisent dans le temps pour éviter
ne prendra pas ce que les raccourcis
sont plus restrictifs que le travail en
vue de construire
même si l'organisation hydra nourrit lui
même si la garde
votre entreprise baptisée 2011 dans la
jungle et en ex parti on le garde
nous sommes tous des marques
ils ont le choix était ma propre
par contre moi même 24 à10 tout seul
soit raté vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]